I've been working on something
[Music]
something better
hey everybody get rekt so Black
Lightning episode 1 this is gonna be my
Easter Egg video it was pretty straight
up from the comics most of the
characters that they're using for the
series are right out of the Black
Lightning comic books there have been a
couple limited runs he's showing up
during justice Lee but if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos obviously there's
a lot of air over stuff happening here
but I will explain how it's connected or
not connected so right at the top of
this I'll say that the producers the
president of the network the showrunner
is saying that it is not connected to
the arrow verse but it is DC TV this is
a TV show with DC Comics characters set
in the DC Universe but they're taking
the material so seriously and they're
dealing with such serious subject matter
that they don't want to be shackled to
the stuff that the flash is doing or
Supergirl or even what's going on on
arrow
so that could always change in the
future but for season 1 it's gonna be
largely self-contained but as you can
see from the episode they're not doing a
traditional origin story like they've
done in the past with the other DC TV
shows like the flash is an origin story
supergirls an origin story arrow was an
origin story so they are flashing back
to his time when he was originally black
lightning 9 years ago so he has the old
version of the costume on when they're
watching that footage from the
convenience store I watched this every
day on my birthday that was probably one
of the funniest moments from the episode
there were a couple of the jokes like
the Harriet Tubman jokes early in the
episode that were a little on the nose
but this is the pilot episode so usually
once they get to the second third fourth
episode they sort of find their stride
and you get into the tone of what the
show's actually going to be usually
pilot episodes aren't always indicative
of what the entire show's gonna be like
but you really only got a teaser for
Tobias whale at the end he's the leader
of the 100 gang I know there's all kinds
of 100 jokes because that's like a whole
other CW show that has absolutely no
connection to the 100 gang from the
comics now in comics like Batman you
have Batman and Beyond so you see
versions of all the characters in the
future there's actually versions of the
100 gang across different eras of DC
Comics so for the most part in present
day there what-you-see-is-what-you-get
they're just a straight-up gang just
controlling the town albeit in a sort of
weird alliance with corrupt
leaders so it's not the suicide slum of
DC Comics but it's something close to
that
so he's closest to what you would think
of is the Superman Supergirl mythos so
if he is gonna cross over with any of
those characters he would probably cross
over with Supergirl characters the real
twist of the episode is that his
daughters are developing superpowers and
I don't know which episode it's going to
happen in but obviously both of them
will eventually just like they did in
the comics if it wasn't clear the
daughters do not know that their father
is black lightning but his ex-wife does
so he wants to get back together with
them but you know they had that whole
flashback where they explained how
they're divorced now the other places
that you may have seen the characters
they did animated cartoons in the comics
the sisters are oh is pretty close in
age but for the most part Anissa the
older one that was getting her powers at
the end of the episode she's more of a
teacher at the school
her younger sister Jennifer is still a
student like she's in class when the 100
gang halls are out and takes her to that
motel they didn't give a timeline for
how long it's gonna be before Anissa
tries to start being a vigilante by
herself but because they don't know
their fathers black lightning and black
lightning doesn't know that they're
developing powers I think you know we're
building towards a funny moment where
they try to take some criminals down
while black lightnings out on the
streets and they just bump into each
other and it's this really awkward funny
moment where they try to explain to each
other oh sorry I have powers I've been a
vigilante this whole time it'd be like
if Laurel and Oliver ran into each other
while they're both being vigilantes
during season one if Laurel had become
Black Canary during season one like oh
wow you're Oliver Queen and you've been
the arrow this whole time oh wow
you're Laurel you've been The Black
Canary this whole time maybe we should
fight together so I think eventually
because they have that family bond
eventually you'll start to see them
fight crime as a family together the
older sister Anissa her name is Thunder
in the comics the younger sisters name
is lightning so you get a thunder and
lightning thunders powers it looks like
on the TV show they're going to be using
as sort of Reverse Kitty Pryde she can
alter her molecular density so when she
breaks that sink she's making herself
super dense this will be kind of funny
but probably the next best comparison to
make would be luke cage's powers like he
has the impenetrable skin now he's way
stronger than
Nissa or like thunder would be in the
comics so she'll be strong but not Luke
Cage strong and she'll have impenetrable
skin and walk around looking like a
normal person she's not gonna have metal
skin like citizen steel or something
like that the younger sister lightning
is a bit of a different scenario because
in the comics she almost just glows
crackling with energy like when black
lightning puts that big aura of energy
behind him imagine if her whole body
looked like that she can fly she has
lightning projection abilities so I
don't know if they're gonna tone that
down a little bit or if they're gonna
make her super fast because that reads a
little bit like the flash she basically
be a backdoor speedster in that scenario
so I think it's gonna be a little bit
different
everybody in my timeline went crazy when
they saw the James remar was gonna be in
this he shows up in all kinds of genre
stuff like this the character that he's
playing Peter gambiae a lot of people
were confused and thought that might be
from the Batman comics but he actually
originated in the Black Lightning comic
book when he's talking to him about
knowing him since he was 12 years old
what happened is is he used to be an
enforcer for the mob he was responsible
for the death of black lightnings father
so it's implied that that's when he sort
of took black like me under his wing as
his penance and turned away from his
life of crime and became his Alfred of
sorts they even have their own version
of the Batcave that looks mysteriously
like Barry's lab from season one I you
know they shooted in Atlanta and they
shot the flash pilot in Vancouver so
it's not the same set it just looks kind
of the same I'm assuming that they'll
also develop their daughters costumes
down there too
like the daughters will probably have
their own proto versions of the costumes
like when they first develop their
powers like Oliver Queen or Barry Allen
they all have early versions of the
costume then later get upgrade so I'm
assuming this season we'll see this
version of her costume relatively
quickly but just let me know in the
comments what do you think of this
series so far do you guys want me to do
weekly videos for this and this is
something that people are really
interested in discussing every week that
I'm totally down to do videos so I
figured I'd do this video see what
everybody thought of it and then we
figured out going forward the few big
action set pieces were pretty good I
loved the fight choreography it'll be
interesting to see what happens when
they're all three fighting together just
based on the way the daughters learn to
use their abilities but training wheels
protocol they'll probably wind up
getting into fights on their own doing
you know small-time vigilantes stuff
before they bump into their father on
the street and they start trying to work
together as a team they do a much better
job of using music than a lot of the
other DC TV shows it does feel like the
heavy atmosphere of a Riverdale TV show
if it was set more around the south side
serpents like darkest timeline Riverdale
jingle-jangle runs rampant that's black
lightning so imagine a superhero rising
out of that so there is a new round of
the Legion ring giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment about the episode on the video
congratulations to the winner from the
video I posted a little while ago Sean
Barse please private message me so I can
get your contact details click here to
learn all about ma Del's new costume and
next week's episode of the flash and
click here for my flash episode 10 video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome see you guys tonight